les 16 et 17 septembre ce sont les
Journées européennes du patrimoine des
rendez-vous devenus incontournables sur
tout le territoire on va faire un petit
tour d'horizon sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec Lucie
Sauvageau bonjour bonjour responsable de
l'action culturelle au musée de la ville
alors Lucie cette année au niveau
national il a deux thèmes qu'on retrouve
à Saint-Quentin le petit le patrimoine
vivant et le patrimoine du sport oui
effectivement deux thèmes cette année un
peu exceptionnel ce sont les 40 ans des
journées du patrimoine d'abord et puis
ce thème du sport forcément vient
s'ajouter au premier thème le patrimoine
vivant puisque évidemment c'est
l'édition juste avant les Jeux
Olympiques quoi faire à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on a notamment
le vélodrome national qui va révéler
quelques secrets c'est ça oui c'est ça
le vélodrome national qui pouvait ouvrir
pour ses journées du patrimoine
heureusement pour nous et qui nous
permet d'avoir des visites guidées le
samedi après-midi qui permettront de
découvrir à la fois l'histoire de ce de
ce monument un dernier né des monuments
50 nuois son environnement puisqu'il est
juste à côté de l'île de loisir sur un
terrain royal qui comportait les le
réseau d'acqueduc et de rigoles qui
alimentaient en eau le château de
Versailles et puis ça nous permet
également de faire des balades à VTT
alors qu'ils seront à la fois l'occasion
d'une initiation au VTT menée par un
coach sportif et puis des commentaires
par nos guides conférenciers sur pareil
l'île de loisirs et l'histoire de
territoire ça fera partie de tête des
dernières fois on pourra accéder au site
avant les Jeux Olympiques c'est
probablement une des dernières fois il y
aura encore des rencontres sportives
avant les Jeux olympiques mais par
contre pour le visiter effectivement ce
sera la dernière possibilité à noter
d'ailleurs que au même moment au même
endroit se tiendra la fête du vélo de
Saint-Quentin donc on pourra prolonger
cet amour sportif sur l'agglomération
l'agglomération il y a le patrimoine
vivant aussi le patrimoine vivant aussi
qui était aussi un thème important de
cette année donc tous les gens qui font
vivre ce patrimoine les métiers de ceux
qui occupent ces monuments tous les
jours donc à 50 ce sera particulièrement
concentré sur les lieux de spectacle
vivant les théâtres notamment puisque
l'agglomération est très très riche de
nombreux lieux culturels trois d'entre
eux ont pu ouvrir leur porte le théâtre
scène national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines là aussi une
dernière fois en travaux une dernière
fois avant travaux puisque effectivement
son aspect en tout cas extérieur va
complètement être modifié à partir de
début 2024 donc pareil dernière fois
qu'on pourra le voir dans sa
configuration actuelle avec cette façade
il sera ouvert le samedi matin et là
c'est l'occasion de faire une visite à
deux voies à la fois sur l'architecture
et l'histoire de ce monument mais aussi
bien sûr les coulisses du théâtre et la
rencontre avec les équipes techniques
c'était toujours passionnant oui c'est
important de mettre en avant ces
personnes qu'on peut dire de l'ombre oui
absolument qu'on voit pas souvent et
vraiment qui sont des gens passionnés et
passionnants donc ça vaut vraiment le
coup c'est toujours des visites qui sont
très très riches il y a le théâtre
Coluche aussi plaisir qui ouvrira ses
portes voilà le théâtre Coluche sur le
dans lequel on pourra en plus aller sans
réservation ce qui est assez rare donc
mon travail profitez-en et qui permettra
d'accéder aux coulisses de rencontrer
pareil les équipes les techniciens autre
salle le prisme alors il n'y a pas que
le spectacle vivant il y a aussi le
patrimoine Saint-Quentin on le sait en
regorge beaucoup le château de la
verrière qui est rarement ouvert le
château de la verrière qui est
exceptionnellement ouvert puisque c'est
le centre de formation de l'amgen donc
la Mutuelle générale de l'éducation
nationale donc il n'est pas ouvert au
public habituellement on ne peut pas le
visiter et c'est un monument en fait
qu'on ne voit que très furtivement peu
de gens savent qu'il existe mais il est
il est passionnant parce qu'il regorge
de quantité d'anecdotes historique de
tous les de tous les siècles on va du
15e siècle jusqu'au 20e et il a vraiment
il a beaucoup de de choses très
insolites à faire découvrir c'est
vraiment une belle pépite pour ces
journées du patrimoine ce genre de
journée ça permet aussi de faire
découvrir des sites qu'on peut visiter
autrement parce que je pense au château
de plaisir d'habitude c'est la
médiathèque c'est le Conservatoire il y
a des secrets que des petites choses
toujours à révéler qu'on peut ignorer
oui alors sur le château de plaisir là
ce sera sous forme de représentation
théâtrale plutôt qui amèneront à avoir
des informations il y a aussi une visite
en autonomie avec un vote smartphone qui
est proposé qui permet de découvrir
l'histoire des lions un petit peu
autrement et oui il y a toujours des
choses à découvrir même si on le voit
tous les jours on imagine pas souvent
l'histoire qui va derrière ces sites et
là son parc en l'occurrence du château
de plaisir alors c'est toujours un peu
la question piège mais s'il y avait un
ou deux rendez-vous à surtout pas noté
on en a dit quelques-uns il y en a bien
sûr beaucoup d'autres dans la
programmation mais si il y avait une
petite nouveauté à ne pas manquer alors
vous avez parlé du prisme tout à l'heure
et le prisme est pas souvent ouvert pour
les Journées du Patrimoine en plus là ce
sera une visite qui sera groupée avec
une visite du quartier mais aussi de la
médiathèque des 7 Mares qui est un
équipement historique de la nouvelle
leçon
qui fêtera d'ailleurs bientôt
aussi ces 50 ans à la médiathèque du 7
mars et puis il y a aussi alors une
petite pépite
qui est absolument il faut réserver
absolument c'est la médiathèque de la du
patrimoine et de la photographie au fort
de Sancy ou encore la BU la bibliothèque
universitaire pareil dont on peut voir
les coulisses le fonctionnement et c'est
très intéressant il faut il faut
dépasser ce qu'on voit quand on marche
dans la rue donc vous l'avez dit le
week-end regorge plein de plein d'autres
rendez-vous rien de plus simple pour les
trouver surtout ne pas les manquer c'est
le site de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou du musée de
la ville merci Lucie Sauvageau j'imagine
que vous donnez rendez-vous au public
les 16 et 17 septembre tout à fait on
vous attend on sera ravi de vous
accueillir le 7 études est maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
notre site Internet et nos réseaux
sociaux bonne soirée sur tv78